et il doit en tant que vous rêviez a une
résidence secondaire ben je crois que
beaucoup de parisiens rêvent de
s'installer un peu à l'extérieur pour
pouvoir ses valets fuir le bruit et la
poussière
fini le stress des villes place au calme
de la campagne milieu des années 60 les
citadins investissent leur résidence
secondaire
le marché est en plein essor et quoi
occuper votre temps quand vous êtes ici
à réparer les en-cas les réparations et
un petit peu de jardinage
à l'époque les transports se développent
certaines régions deviennent plus
facilement accessibles alors le citadin
en profitent ils achètent une maison
neuve ou en rénovation
ce qui profite à l'économie locale comme
ici dans une petite commune du loir et
cher
j'ai travaillé beaucoup les gens du pays
on est peut-être communes rurales on
n'aurait pas mourir on fait tout ce
qu'on peut au conseil municipal pour les
lotissements pour essayer de lancer des
deux côtés cuisines en fête pour pas
mourir dans les années 70 le phénomène
des résidences secondaires prend encore
de l'ampleur
le citadin continuent de fuir la ville
dès qu'il peut à l'image de cette
famille qui vient d'acheter une maison
dans le département de la loire
c'était en 1976 un cadre de détente un
cadre de détente d'un repos une journée
ici on se sent bien
deux journées un sommier à moi
après le boom des années 70 arrive le
temps du déclin
début des années 80 le pays est touché
par la crise économique les français ont
plus de mal à emprunter et le marché des
résidences secondaires s'essouffle ils
ont clé tout à l'époque devait être de
l'ordre de entre 12 et 15% en maintenant
j'ai rien trouvé en dessous de 18 19 ans
grosso modo ça fait mais francs de plus
par mois à patienter mais c'est le
calcul que j'ai fait en plus de la crise
le comportement des français change
en 1988 il privilégie les séjours
organisés au détriment des maisons de
campagne trop cher à entretenir
résultat les ventes chutent c'est vrai
que les ventes de résidences secondaires
sans toutefois disparaître on quelque
peu diminué nous le constatons tous les
jours en 1988 deux millions six cent
quatre-vingts 3000 résidences
secondaires étaient recensés en france
contre 3 millions 597 me l'an 2020 selon
l'insee un chiffre record dû notamment à
la crise du coc vite 19
[Musique]